so welcome back to the iced coffee hour
my name is Graham we got Andrew Hales
joining us and we got Jack's so in this
episode we're gonna be talking about a
whole bunch of things you're gonna be
talking about YouTube pranks we're gonna
be going over your finances we're gonna
be talking about what else we're gonna
be talking credit card debt credit card
debt that's a big one
making money in general and YouTube
pranks on YouTube
pranks on YouTube the famous people
you've met some of the stuff that you've
learned along the way
hmm and what else am I missing it's
gonna yeah the credit card thing is
gonna be a little embarrassing but you
know it is what it is you know so well
it's a good episode today so a stay
tuned and it's a vulnerable episode
let's let's begin nice done perfect and
cool done intro it or you want to go
ahead and intro it and just say hey
we're here with Andrew Edwards this is
the main camera and this is side all
right right okay cool
so welcome back to the iced coffee hour
my name is Graham this is Jack we got
Andrew Hales LOF a man channel law fella
hwf good to have you on now this is like
almost a reverse chatting with ya have
you ever been chatted with before yeah
yeah I mean I I've been on a few podcast
whatever it's okay it's not too hard
okay how do you feel about this Jack I'm
super excited I actually watched a ton
of your videos growing up you know doing
the pranks and of course through the
transition into the chatting wish I
watched those I think they're great I
really liked your content because I
thought you were more like down-to-earth
like I knew for a fact you weren't
faking your stuff like I was during a
time where everyone was like faking
faking we should really quick do an
introduction I know it's weird talking
about yourself do you want us to talk
about you for you or you want you want
to introduce yourself a little bit for
for people who are tuning in who are
like wait who's who's loft who's Andrew
house it would be easier if you did okay
he's got over 2 million subscribers on
his main channel yak what like 350 400
thousand on your second yeah but that
one's like extinct now I don't add too
and but yeah but you did some of the og
pranks what I would really like to call
it like in the beginning of YouTube's
whole prank days you were really one of
the top pranksters yeah I mean it's my
yeah I'd say it was like like in 2012
when it was all fresh I'd say it was
like me and maybe 10 other guys were
doing it yeah but you had some really
unique ones that I thought were really
cool like going up and grabbing people's
hand mm-hmm yeah that was one of our
first viral ones yeah they're totally
harmless - yeah I mean I'm you know I'm
kind of I'm kind of a softie I can't
really I'm bad at confronting people get
your phone Graham man I Drive all the
way down here for this there we go is
that a client
no my buddy was thinking about buying a
Tesla and one of my thoughts in the
model why so I said do it but he's got
to use my referral link mama why is that
is the model why new yeah that's a new
one so it's it that's the in between the
three and the X the like the truck thing
that like looks like a video game it's
cyber truck yeah did that defect go away
I feel like I heard about it and then
like I never saw it on the road anyway
wants to move forward with that I think
it's gonna be a stretch to actually put
that car on the road it looks extremely
unsafe like if you get in a car accident
you're demolishing whatever car you hit
so I think it's just about making it
road safer I don't say for the other
people right oh yeah it's incredibly
safe yourself
I'm like have you seen any of them on
the road yeah no there's not Elon Musk
rides his around but yeah if you can't
get bleep it out all right cool yeah but
anyway so going back to this one of the
og YouTube pranksters do you want to be
known as a YouTube prankster like what
what do you don't care is like whatever
people you know say whatever I am be
known I don't I don't care I'm sure do
you go by like YouTube we're different
okay like merchants because you know you
have like just youtuber is the most
simple you know youtuber is like is
where it is you know
just you know make youtube videos so
when you when you meet someone new you
tell them I'm a youtuber yeah yeah you
sometimes I like I'll be in that uber
and I don't want to say that because
then there's like a hundred to
conversation questions you know you know
20 years later one question with
youtubers but no yes sometimes I'll just
yeah I'm in real estate or something you
didn't mass gram if he tells people that
that you know that he's a youtuber and
he said no I usually just say I'm in
real estate so I thought you would seen
it yeah you know start trading or just
something it's true though I don't tell
people I do YouTube it's a whole bunch
of questions but I remember telling
someone when another real estate agent
who's asking like oh you know how busy
are you I'm like you know I haven't
really been that busy because I've been
focusing on my time on YouTube they're
like oh what's on YouTube but like I
make videos on YouTube
oh it doesn't make any money in that and
like a little bit a little bit of money
in that majority of your income right at
this point yeah yeah it is the
quarantine make it so you don't sell
houses as much it made me focus more in
YouTube I mean ya know really for the
last a year and a half I placed my
emphasis really on YouTube yeah that's
just there's there's a window of
opportunity and I figured like now is my
chance to make the most of it if I don't
do this now what am I gonna have this
chance again so I wanted to go full
force
cool yeah no but don't worry well we'll
talk to you so anyway so we got the
background of you down and you do
YouTube full-time I mean this is this is
your full-time your thing oh yeah I've
made it like eight years now just off
youtube I did a little bit of postmates
deliveries the last couple months I feel
like you just showed the stones and they
think it's a prank like yeah I know that
happened with you
oh you that guy and then he gave me a
fat tip so but no I what was the
question
yeah like the quarantine has made
everything halted for a second when
especially with the chatting z' and
everyone cancelled on that and yeah I've
just been trying to survive you know how
was address movement for you over the
last few months has it gotten down have
you noticed a spike cuz I've noticed a
spike in viewership like my ad rates
went down but viewership doubles yeah
people are going on it I think the last
six months I've been losing on average
about a thousand subscribers mm-hm
just I don't know just like filtering
out like you know we stopped at chatting
with and like I started doing all these
random vlogs and random videos I love
this yeah yes the quarantine kind of
style going my game is going crazy it's
hard to shift your content around if you
pivot in any sort of way you're gonna
lose an audience it takes time to build
the back up and then you build it up you
shift it again mm-hmm want to go back to
pranks
cuz I'm old now I just can't do it it's
not in me it's like it's like forcing
you to play GI Joes you know it's I just
can't do it well I could try to force it
and fake it for the money but it just it
sounds so pretentious but just the the
passion wouldn't be there anymore you
know yeah if you were to ever do another
prank video would you invite Graham
alone I would do it always everyone used
to wanna do praying with videos - yeah
would love to - that's the thing it
looks really fun but it's not that fun
it depends on the prank but it's just no
it's still work you know it's still
you're still like stalking you're still
stopping people on the street mm-hmm and
you're like you're still kind of yeah
you're still performing you're still
kind of like selling them I mean I mean
it's the awkward part is afterward
getting their permission like hey this
is all fake is okay we use this footage
how many people say no it's just taxing
not a lot of people like 10% but like
still it's and it also doing it in the
real world is really different I I was
getting older and older and still doing
these pranks on college campuses where
it's so much easier to do pranks because
everyone's like in their bubble of
Education the parents are paying and
they haven't really seen the real world
yet and everyone everything's rainbows
and ice cream you know yeah and so you
can and all the hot girls are there and
it's just the best place to do pranks
and when you do in the real world it's
like everyone just thinks you're a
homeless person or something I bothering
man or a peddler you know you don't look
out of place at a college campus if you
were to college can yes you look like
you belong there yeah sure but still
it's like I I was getting sick alone I
just wanted to move on and thankfully
you know the chatting was for working
out and I'm gonna probably keep doing
those for now now is your in it has
there ever been a prank that you've done
that you thought was like perfect like
you're like this is viral but then at
the last minute they said well I I don't
want myself on YouTube there is there
any footage oh no no no well not gonna
not that I can think of there's I mean I
yeah there's like pranks we've done
sorry there's dumb pranks we've done
where you know I'll just don't list it
like a year later and so that no one
ever sees it why cuz just cuz I hate it
like it's either the audience hated and
I agree with that we got into an example
and I want to know what you deleted I
think there's one called like
rock-paper-scissors prank or something
that I did in 2012 and I was just going
up to people and hey rock paper scissors
they're like alright and they do it and
then like whatever they did I would just
you'd be I would switch it yeah and it
just was I just was like it wasn't funny
and so I was like it was a nice sword
so that's I'd say like every 20 videos
I've listed them eventually oh yeah so
there's a lot that I've enlisted I'm
compiling that list and it that's on
patreon that's alright because I feel
like any video you would do because you
are you people would just like they find
it funny
ya know that's the thing like the
ratings are fine or whatever they're
just like cool love you Andrew but it's
only but it's up anyways yeah these you
may as well just leave it up like it's
already up there yeah but it's like I
feel like it just hurts the overall
chain of videos like if they're if they
watched that one they're like alright
this and then they get bored and they
move on you're something else you know
shamonite notices if we do delete a
video it actually throws off our house
at the algorithm and it snows down our
channel and you wait less views for the
next couple of months the algorithm is
terrible yet deleting or private Anor
unlisting a video is one of the worst
things you could do for a channel oh my
seriously it's it's screwed up the
algorithm for months after like private
e even like not even big videos that's
one of the things that I have I that we
that I figured out a way around this I
knew like don't hire me a Moneyball no
type ii don't know all this stuff you
know one of the ways around this that I
found Jack Jack and I actually tested
this out for one of the videos instead
of deleting the video because that
that's gonna hurt your channel what you
do instead is you the cat guys what you
do instead is you go to the YouTube
editor and you edit out the entire video
you just leave the outro so the video is
still up there oh but you could delete
the video by removing all of its
contents and then the editor saves the
original version on file so if you ever
want to undelete the video you could go
and just revert it back to its original
even but it's like half a million views
it lets you edit it cuz I've tried oh
you know what there might be a thing
where it's over certain might be I mean
we've little deep you know under 110,000
okay
it was funny I I don't know if we leave
this in but it's the tie was just outro
MOV people want to find that video they
could find it and it's like five seconds
long I don't want to go into specifics
but basically we had someone on the
channel who agreed and consented to be
on the channel was not happy with the
outcome of the call what's happy with
the outcome of the call but
afterwards didn't like some of the
common resolution you they asked you to
take it to something afterwards yes so
stopped comments so people wouldn't know
which video that was and yeah it's
called it out road movie and then just
the thumbnails the algorithm all meaning
like it doesn't send so how are things
well what was gonna say the it throws
off the algorithm meaning like it
doesn't send out new videos to your
subscribers as well know what we
guessing it's like valuable impressions
so like the amount it pushes your videos
so the algorithm is like something that
determines how much they want your video
to be shown to people
hmm and if you have like a bad algorithm
that means that they don't really push
your video onto viewers
so yeah the monetized video immediately
is not Gandhi monetized video is
probably gonna be pushed like
significantly less or words that are
like shadow band for example ELISA right
like for a time as you said that they
would shadow ban and push your video
yeah it's really like political like
have I got other thing it's like I gotta
get your number and get all this info
yeah we'll help you out anytime you need
it
alright let's see you got two channels
ones the grant three little brighter
okay I've got it
Graham Stefan show that's sorry guys
yeah really quickly just a quick recap
yeah the cat goes over to the Ottoman
and then does you know with cats are
excited to go does it on the Ottoman and
so I wanted to grab the spray foam just
maximum I just yeah is that what the
spray bottles for doesn't yeah yeah
usually to shake it and she knows he
doesn't to get when did you get his cat
here we go oh yeah so once kind of just
barely growing out of the kitten face
it's cool
so anyway so so yes so that the
algorithm is forced to be recomment yeah
all right how do you guys figure that
stuff out
a lot of testing a lot of it yeah I
spend studying the analytics I spend it
probably at least an hour to day just
watching analytics and seeing like which
videos are getting pushed I've been so
long you're getting pushed for what
types of videos get pushed the CPM like
we Jack and I look for the first hour
when a video is posted and like it
doesn't give a [ __ ] like a ha oh yeah it
doesn't get a certain number of views in
the first like five minutes
like the first minute two minutes I'm
like it was a title the title we missed
title we got to retitle the video it's
later then we know it's if it's later
than if it's later than like 20 minutes
we know it's the thumbnail so if you see
a big spike in views and then it just
immediately goes down it's a thumbnail
how do you do that because why how do
you know is based off of like the
changes that we've made in the past yeah
so yo yeah this is this is some probably
years or the test and you think oh wait
- this building you guys could write a
book on all this yeah well that would
create our Academy bolts for sale well
the YouTube creator Academy link down
below in the description about this one
hundred bucks off throw $100 off down
below in the description greater than
you'll get free access to that I'll give
you free access I all I ask for in
return is just an honest review sure
that's it if you don't like it just be
honest cool if you like it be honest
that's all just an honest review and
then is free congratulations yeah but
yeah so there were like we've posted
videos and they will rank it as a 10
which is like the lowest performing
video of like you know it's 10 most
recent videos and we've changed the
thumbnail or change the title and
brought it back up to like a fox
oh my gosh oh yeah that's resurrecting
ideas I need to read that ASAP well oh
there was one in a bunch of videos or
that's eight hours of footage all right
this is not this is not planted by the
way alright but I really was organic
yeah but there are ways there are ways
to save a video that's not doing one
there's one video this is this is what
started it off about two years ago I
made a video
Robin Hood and it just the video just
didn't get any views and try to feel out
what's wrong what's wrong the video I
changed the title and thumbnail I forget
what it was and just immediately you see
the views just like going right back up
and it just continued growing four hours
after with it turned a horrible video
into like on a banger hush I'd forget
what it was but oh I think it was like
the problem with Robin Hood or like what
you need to know about Robin or
something like that and now it's like
one of the most viewed videos in Robin
Hood yeah a lot of these chain of Teflon
youtubers they push YouTube Academy
stuff you know and I always think it's
scammy but this doesn't sound like a
scam that sounds like you paid me I that
I swear you did not pay FTC disclosure I
had no idea so yeah so at some point we
could look through your channel go
through it and figure out but anyway
let's get back and you know what I feel
like and we're at a point now we're just
talking about Finance because a lot of a
lot of people watch my channel to care
about personal finance they don't know
how much money you're making how much
are you saving how much your expenses
are you feel comfortable telling us some
of that stuff you want to get this out
if you don't sure yeah okay so I think
I'm about $30,000 in credit card debt
right now no yeah
wait it no you're kidding
no yeah like I don't belong on this your
channel we got a Frankston you know I do
you want being serious yeah I just spent
a lot last year would never remember
where I used to live yeah yeah so so I
saw this on Angie's place five hundred
dollars thirty seven hundred bucks a
month
oh and I was like for reference I also
went to Russia and Japan and my hair
okay yes I'm so I'm sorry about like
laughing I thought you were no nice look
a couple times in my life and I always
get out of it like I can just pump out a
few more video that's so let's talk
about it let's back up sir um how did
you how did you get what credit card did
you get no it usually starts with like
owing taxes and so then I'll throw like
20 or 30 grand on a credit card to pay
off my taxes and then with the rent last
year was 3700 a month and then videos
kept getting to monetize and then you
know just you know falling into partying
too much whatever and just you know okay
I mean I take full responsibility
I don't where's the debt being held on
what interest rate are you paying on it
oh it's probably ridiculous I'd probably
have paid 3 or 4 grand in interest alone
this year okay so so here's the thing
though keep expecting like just kidding
yeah no it's not so we're gonna do a
money make up and sure yeah that's no
I've already read the Total Money
Makeover yeah okay when you say all the
savings straight to his credit no what I
would say the best no no you right now I
have a good idea actually with inflation
it's free money no no okay so in all
seriousness all you need to do this will
save you a few thousand dollars make
sure to put an ad break right here okay
because we're leading up to this the
camera the slave you few thousand
dollars you want to do a balance
transfer oh sure and what what's
happened I've already done those no I
mean like I just I've tried to do that
but my credits not good enough okay I
think it's like 500 600 now Wow deep
because did you miss payments that's not
from yeah yeah I got a car now I'm
paying car payments but it's not it's
not that that's just that would help you
but that's gonna help you it's the only
reason your score is the way it is
he's missed me yeah utilization sure
things have you missed I don't know
three or four I don't know okay enough
do you have anything in collections that
you know what you mean savings
collections
what's collection Oh like a debt is no I
don't think it's so neat I don't think
it's gone that for okay so it's it's not
too late Z okay you have a cosigner do
you have somebody no okay
your best bet honestly is you gotta
throw everything in the savings
everything you mean take everything out
of savings whatever you have in savings
right just barely enough because here's
the thing my thinking is it in an
emergency you could always put more
money back in the credit cards mm-hmm if
you need to you could spend money and
credit cards get up the debt again
that's fine well I did get unemployment
and that's that that helped a lot yeah
so I paid off a bunch with that and so
my credit rating should just jump up
later I wouldn't be concerned about your
credit rate how did you rent your place
how did they perfect see the credits car
and then no no well back in December I
think it was good enough it was like six
ninety or something okay but I still had
to put down two months of rent and that
was hard
I don't know a lot of things happened to
I got my car broken into
they stole four thousand dollars where
the camera equipment there's a thousand
dollars to replace the window of my car
I file an insurance claim for that he's
four thousand significant enough where
you could file through insurance a lot
of times your homeowners insurance would
cover that so until I didn't have
renter's insurance at that point okay
that's nothing always get renters
insurance a story word like the opposite
in um financial we should do a thing a
pen and make oh I'm just gonna pump out
some chatting with this has happened
before and I just I pay it all back and
I'm fine but yeah I probably won't use
credit cards anymore you know I'm thirty
it's time to grow up you know it's okay
to use credit cards it's just well do it
do you feel like you can't trust
yourself to use a credit card
yeah that's the thing I don't know like
my self-control and stuff you know
then don't be a card then again I agree
yeah paid off those at the cards I would
keep one card open
you're right do you like to read 500
limit or whatever a thousand limit on
the habit my dog just had surgery like
two weeks ago and it's $700 yes so many
things happen you know this is so cool
so you mentioned you could pump out next
video what would it reach video make
like if you do a training with well the
patreon has been helping with the
demonetised videos which are like
controversial videos talk no I think
you're fine yeah I'm watching this but
um no like that's a thing that's why I
want to start this what's crazy is the
stock trading the the first stock
trading Millionaire I talked to whom are
like two years ago is like still top
three earning video on my channel yeah
yeah my thing is this if you're on
YouTube you got a plane to YouTube yeah
they they have specific guys like these
bond that you gotta follow yeah yeah and
as long as you follow it I feel like
YouTube is there to reward you but you
gotta follow it so that's know yeah so
no content that's questionable hmm he's
got to think too if your YouTube got
this big audience why would you push
something that maybe the audience might
find offensive or be like you know I
don't like this on you I'm going back to
it I guess it's an art it's an artistic
thing you know you're just you're
passionate about the topic or the video
you know I get that but then that's not
that's not a business and that yeah
that's a passion thing and then that's
for Facebook you post those on Facebook
it's true
true those were for Facebook and then
you post the business stuff everything
you know the serious business talks on
on YouTube yeah you know what it's like
yeah there's a balance you have to find
with you know expressing yourself or
whatever and the business yeah I think
that's right for at least you I think
that it is you know it's between those
things yeah you just yeah cuz I don't
know I'll get miserable if I just start
posting top ten credit cards you know
every day
listen okay I get just like you know
like I got up I got a postcard said my
yeah we just have different
personalities whatever you know what
that's the thing there are videos on my
channel I'm not gonna mention them
specific there are some of those videos
on my channel I can't stand making yeah
at all but people love them love them so
it's like every few months I'm like one
of these again how do I do it and people
love it and find it helpful it's just I
feel like I've done it so many times
it's not like me like pranks like I know
if I just surprise them with a prank
though I'll like immediately like it
even if it sucks you know do one just
stealing people's shopping carts I try
to go do it like a month ago but it was
still weird cuz everyone had masks on
and I was like I was using like these
plastic gloves and it was just yeah yeah
this year's this year's has been what do
you want that will also have a high CPM
do it like stealing people's shopping
carts or with a millionaire Graham
Stefan no I already thought of some
pranks that have would have a high CPM
okay Starbucks and start us you know
that was like a pick-up video like
Starbucks and start us what start is
like a it's an alternative to Netflix
and chill o start us yeah it's still a
bit boy KFC and you know what why don't
you do what I really need I don't know
no had a really funny prank where they
would call in but had a really funny
Frank where they would call in and just
quit places they didn't work out I love
those videos okay why don't you know
I've seen that video a million times I'm
not gonna do that video use cuz it's
like not original I don't know like you
have the peel of yourself like people
like you as a person I I kind of on this
I'm indulgent with my boy what I want to
pose a little too much I got something I
got something quick I thought this would
actually be really interesting we ever
did a prank video you do a challenge to
see who could keep the person on the
phone the longest so like let's say
right now we all have to call
McDonald's let's assume so you can pick
a random McDonald's and whoever keeps
that person on the phone kiss wins I
don't know what it is keep them on the
phone is it the same person we're
calling yeah okay you get to pick the
place the same place yeah same business
so I can I do it like different days oh
yeah like you could go and pick at
McDonald's now and then I'll pick a big
dog our Jack will think of McDonald's
and then we each calm like I'm calling
about this and then we time it Andrew
you gotta do a prank all right let's get
back to the credit card let's just
attack this really far everyone is
something else you really think if you
just started doing a few buddies you can
just knock it so it's not of course
issue no I'm not it's not the same as
like having like a real job you know
$60,000 a year job it's you know desk
job and having that day it's like the
money as an entrepreneur in YouTube and
everything the money a lot of money
comes in at once and a lot of money goes
out well that's my fault out part but
yeah right did you have you gotta meet
calm and like made a budget yes I've
done stuff like that but it's you know
it's the thing is I could like I get
some videos could make like twenty
thousand dollars in the next couple
months and and it's all taken care of
you know I think most likely a spending
problem so saving problem so yeah course
I spent a lot last year is there
spending like relatively like so audible
so what does it like or do you go
through periods of time where you just
start spending a lot of money and then
you know you go into a time where you
don't spend so much well so like last
year I was starting to like on average
20 like 15 20 grand a month you know Wow
yeah you know and so so I was just like
oh I can I can go to Japan I can go to
Paris I'm fine but then it just like
shrunk from 15 a month down to like
three grand a month within a couple
months it was you know I'm learning my
lesson it likes you know though you make
3 grand a month
yeah there's saw anything after that
just goes towards your credit card debt
and savings that's it 3 grand a month
and you'll live 3 grand a month until
you make it so much money where then you
could spend 4 thousand I got to start
buying like assets and stuff yeah I got
this house right yeah yeah it's
beautiful
thanks you had it for two months two
months closed on it in February didn't
move in to the end of March and then had
no furniture until this recently mm-hmm
so very nice but yeah so it's to attack
the credit card debt yeah I know don't
you know oh yes I get that get that
taken off what else is on the agenda for
today would it be god I think well a lot
of people are in debt right like it's a
big industries the debt relief programs
and all that you think those are a scam
a lot of them take advantage of the
situation I mean here's the thing it
you're a higher risk if any sort of
lender is out there you have a higher
chance of not paying it back than
someone else with a good credit score so
they have to charge more money because
the default rates of those are a lot
higher hmm so they have to but there's
also an element of some people have no
other place to go so they know they
could charge more money because you
don't have an option so if you want like
a payday advance or anything like that
or any sort you you have very few
options so you kind of have to take the
deal so there is an element to that it's
a little shark ish but it's just it's
also risk and they have to be
compensated for the risk mm-hmm not the
entire industry is not shady but it
can't take advantage of the situation
well no yeah I I almost signed up for
this one thing where they're like yeah
just one little small payment of
whatever 200 bucks a month and you're
all your debt will be cleaned up in 18
months or whatever it was like a bunch
of lawyers you know that oh I guess they
just they're on the phone and they try
to bargain with chase whatever yeah and
that's the end but then like in the fine
print I almost missed it it was like but
no but then there's like this 75 bucks a
month thing and all this
some of those not good those those are
credit repair companies and some of
those can be good and you get the right
people and they send like template
letters out to your creditors they'll
get items removed they know all the ins
and out it can be worth it but not all
of them are like that mm-hmm
some of them can be good down some of
them are bad yeah I noticed you you've
been doing a weeble mm-hmm has that been
good yeah and that's all perk that's
just all commission you're do free
stocks down below in the description
very nice it sounds like you're just
plugging everything and you got your
real estate agent Academy - how is that
going oh great down below in description
a hundred dollars on it's just like oh
cool and you got your Amazon affiliate
yeah the link to that is down no it's
just an honest question like yeah trying
to figure out what I can do you know and
the weebles reached out to me to do that
- hello Ivan but I like my get volume -
Sega stock trader so my god I can't I
get that I guess so yeah you could
always just drop that referral link in
the like the description of your stock
trader videos just leave it in there
right yeah there's any current you know
viewers right yeah it's a seed so let's
talk about a youtube when you first
started prank videos do you have any
sort of inspiration it was a youtuber
that led you to do that not really any
youtuber is just like jacks and stuff
you know you make skate videos in high
school and you do stuff that wouldn't
public and we just eventually did that
in 2012 and a few of them went viral but
yeah I think I learned that you could
make money off youtube like off ads
before the videos like in 2010 and then
that's when I was like alright so
there's something there and before that
I was doing that Italian ice pushkar
business for like six months and Tony
nice pushcart business yeah what's that
Italian ice it's like it's like a more
hard slushy you eat with a spoon and I
was doing that at like events and fairs
slushy yeah it's so yeah Italian ice you
never had that oh I think it
how ionized oh sorry Italian ice mm I
was doing that I had affairs or affairs
and like events and stuff and that was
like a you know how old were you at that
time 21 22 but then luckily you know and
I was doing the YouTube on the side and
then one of them blew up and I saw like
700 bucks in my adsense account as I go
up this is way easier and I just kept it
and quit immediately
thank you wait I think I quit after
about a month from that because then the
holding hands blew up and that made like
30 grand and I'm in a week and I was
like oh man I gotta keep doing their 30
grand in a week
yeah because back then the you know
Adsense was a lot higher Wow
yeah I come up with that idea holy hands
yeah I don't know just how you come up
with any ideas this seemed you just
thought she's doing something awkward in
public you know yeah yeah I didn't and
we didn't think it would like blow up or
anything you know we just thought it
would be another I remember watching
that that first came out seriously Wow
yeah and I thought it was just funny and
it was so just like why didn't it such a
simple idea yeah
it's entertaining yeah very enter you
know to give the viewers a better like
idea should be like link one of the
videos or something yeah put it down
below in this holding hands video down
yeah it'll be right below
wiebel right below the YouTube creator
Academy above Amazon affiliate Barry
knows they actually did a shout out in
the beginning for an Amazon when you get
like you know 1% of yes oh yeah you know
what's so funny quick quick you know
side tangent Rose in the very beginning
before I monetized anything the first
thing I did was Amazon affiliate links
Wow and one of the videos I like
recommended a few books and I put the
book links down below in the description
and those books you'll make maybe like 5
cents or 10
cents per book sold I think maybe on a
good day you make like a dollar and
someone got so upset like DRAM I can't
believe that you would be monetized
you're just a talking head to push books
on Amazon wow it's like I spent like
eight hours on this video yeah
to make a dollar back maybe on a good
like on a good mom well they can also
like click other stuff and you get some
sales back then I think I'm making maybe
five bucks a month or something
something like that I mean it was for
the amount of time I put on YouTube but
who was your favorite person on the
chatting besides me yeah obviously
probably the expert on narcissism she
you know she was just a professor from
Cal State Los Angeles and I read her
book and I was really well prepared and
I think narcissism and you know psycho
stuff and all that you know it's all
interesting and psychology and I thought
I just thought that interview went
really well and so right now I have that
as the the channel trailer what have you
learned about narcissism and psychology
that we might not know yeah you see you
see I feel like a lot of people are know
oh yeah everyone is in our system yeah
you know there's a spectrum yeah and I
mean her in her book she kind of talks
about how the real narcissists are like
we're very charming and you just don't
see it and you know a lot of people you
date maybe that you really liked could
be narcissist but that's like cliche you
know they just broke your heart what's
the difference between narcissism and
confidence
I don't remember right now okay probably
negatively effects is more just like
upon yourself narcissism you can put
down others narcissism is it's just
excessive you know it's it's shameless
excessive confidence empty confidence
that you can kind of just see but most
people don't see you know and maybe it's
a cell
fishness yeah maybe maybe that's it's
more of a self-entitlement
yeah I'm very entitled yeah it's a
disorder apparently yeah that's what she
claims so you're born with it you're
born you're born a narcissist I don't
remember if you're born that is one of
the questions I asked but I remember
what she says yeah like narcissism is
something that would be shaped by your
upbringing and like your your life
experiences and maybe that's a coping
mechanism for something yeah I don't
feel like someone would be just boring
but maybe I yeah I wish I could remember
right now but it was like something like
Psychopaths are born it but narcissists
are you comment you know mm-hmm so I
don't know it's just I need to I need to
go watch the video again what about
people who smash like button for YouTube
algorithm if you guys have done that
okay I gotta start doing all those
little things
smash that like button yeah like in the
vlogs yeah yeah gosh I gotta just still
do that though that's it so yeah it's do
I gotta start I gotta start playing you
do you know what it's like I started
doing that when I saw Logan and Jake
Paul being so over-the-top
I remember Logan Paul this is like maybe
two and a half years ago had a plate
that he was holding and I was just like
that's funny so I started saying in my
videos
at first it was supposed to be like
satire like make sure you guys smash
that like button for the YouTube app but
people liked it it's sorry just now it's
been years yeah it's just I can't I
gotta keep saying it now because now and
then it then it sort of you know yeah I
mean this just start like overly
animated you know
vlog a little series on guys
you know just like we called yeah it
would be called whatever the vlog is
then wine influencer your audience would
freak and for those that haven't watched
you know I think they would love it very
calming sort of monotone it's just you
know but you keep in all the parts of it
like I've seen your vlogs real basically
to sit there for like 30 seconds not
saying it you'll sit there and you'll
smack your mouth it's like they my blog
audience has a lot of patience like
sharing yeah yeah for like a minute yes
yeah so but I feel like if you did
anything different than that your
audience with it's wrong is you do
something something else well no no they
would know if I did this animated they
would immediately know I'm like Joe but
I think that would be really funny to do
that though okay I gotta get to that an
animated Andrew new channel you don't
just start a new channel you know that's
I've learned that lesson I don't know do
you think that you're you focus more in
the future on the now probably than now
yeah like yeah no I definitely I think
if I focused more on the future I
wouldn't have my credit card debt you
know the marshmallow thing that's the
kids with the kids with the marshmallow
thing you know you do you have like a
five year plan or a three year plan
not really I have a like a six month
plan but I eventually want to make films
and make enough money to make scones and
produce yeah screen writing producing
directing you just but you need money a
lot of money for all that type of stuff
but um why not do that on YouTube dude I
think I do laughs was good have you
three times
oh wow sometimes like cringe at it cuz
it's like kind of like sappy and cheesy
it's good thanks
how old are you 21 ma'am I don't know I
just uh like I made laughs when I was 19
and it's just as I've grown older it's
like it becomes like I kind of see with
it for what it is it's just a little
extreme you know the author was
depressed obviously you know the movies
just a little hyped up and I just I
don't want people to think I'm obsessed
with that movie and I kind of thought
you were no I'm really not
obviously I've never seen yeah oh you
haven't seen five gluttons great movie
yeah it's out there it's a good film
Thomas on it I would say it's like top
20 but not top ideas yeah I mean you
probably like a lot losses yeah well
yeah that's like that was an impulse
like one night I just made laughs and
then it just became it kind of just grew
losing all hope was freedom yeah that's
what laughs no I had no idea
quote from the movie yeah I always
thought it was to take on laughs yeah
like yeah good laughs he's off yeah so
that's the more commercial brand
friendly version okay I didn't know that
but so I don't know but it's it's
honestly kind of a terrible channel name
no one can pronounce that no one can
spell it yeah time I spelt the wrong way
but then YouTube will correct me and it
knows it knows enough because honestly
like awkward Andrew something easy to
remember if I from the beginning I
wonder if like how many more views or
subs or anything if I simply just named
everything awkward Andrew you could have
double right yeah so that's yeah yeah
people fit it to whatever narrative they
want like a lot of people have asked me
about their channel names and my advice
is always if people can't easily spell
it
then don't name your channel that right
they got to be able to cuz really you
have to appeal to someone who's never
heard of it you say what's your channel
awkward Andrew you know about that right
well you can spell
think that double off is like you know
like just terrible yeah
it just sounds kind of great I'll go to
Andrew that sounds Mickey Mouse yeah
yeah sounds like Blue's Clues never too
late I almost changed everything to
chatting with which is easy to remember
and spell I I don't love it I like
something with your name in it because I
think your name is your brand and it's
easier because chatting with didn't you
corner yourself into just chatting wits
and I think a little bit should beyond
yourself you already you know so yeah
just stick with laughs screw you no no
it's too late I can't change the talent
everyone will be pissed like I was
always here when it was I can already
see me the more comments something gets
better boosted for the algorithm so if
everyone's like I was here who would
well or like like this comment if you
were here before you know awkward Andrew
I think people like to know that you're
still like somewhat the same you know
even though yeah do the prank videos at
all like to know like if you completely
change to only chat anyways it would be
a little weird things actually when
first meeting you because I've seen your
videos and you were the exact same
person yeah times crazy yeah every way
have you met other youtubers and they
weren't the exact same person I actually
don't think I met anybody had no name
drop but yeah whatever you pretty much
the same purse yeah a lot more calm
though I mean this is really more what
I'm like now like what I want to go home
and just do that yeah just the
influencer yeah yeah well I guess it's
you
I don't think I've ever met anybody
there were certainly people I've met
where you know what they've shown online
is not exactly who they are but but yeah
everyone else exaggerated a little bit
right but no I guess I guess you're
right well I I thought a lot of what you
would do is just a little more like
acting for YouTube you know interest
just the manner is
saying just it for some of the prank
videos yeah it's it's you yeah yeah I
mean a lot of a lot of people think like
I'm they yeah they were they wonder if
I'm like really awkward in my life and I
always say like it's like 50/50 I don't
think that you're awkward Thanks I think
I think people are only awkward if they
think that they're awkward for example
yeah I yeah it's a lot early ever
experience awkwardness like in the
typical awkward scenario I just feel
normal
I'm okay sitting with someone in silence
so look at mr. fancy pants or an
extrovert most I think most extroverts
have never experienced like awkwardness
like my mom Danny dunked in to name a
few or I've never I've never I've never
felt awkward around them because they're
extroverts and they just they just not
even their brain at all like they don't
they just don't know that experiences no
yeah I have a isfp do you know what you
are I think or is that what you're
taught there like what different
personality types yeah yeah I mean it's
it's a it's like a um scale
have you taken one gram mm-hmm you know
you are so you know you don't really
care about it yeah I did it for a video
it's not hard science for sure
were there any prank videos that you did
and you looked back on it alright we've
already answered this and you're talking
this to cringey to where you so were you
had to delete it you know the dozen
couple dozen I remember you are on an
interview show or something and you said
that you didn't want to face fake taffy
or something like that
you peed your pants oh yeah yeah oh my
god I was on an interview show it was
like you a thing yeah alright yeah we
have like a device up in Corrigan we
were trying to do peeing my pants in
front of people and it was it was too
awkward it was people were like are you
okay and like treating you know treating
me like like that is special ed or
something
that's like coupled with your
personality like it was it wasn't it
wasn't it just wasn't funny wasn't it
was just too real yeah so yeah they just
thought I was there's something wrong
with me you know and it wasn't it didn't
feel like a prank anymore you know so we
just scrapped the whole thing that make
sense I don't think I don't think you
could find that footage anywhere I don't
even think we put it on the computer
yeah so you gotta try things and yeah
yeah you never would have done the
hand-holding thing would have been such
a hit I mean you hear that yeah it's
gonna lay him do something else ya know
so I mean I don't even think that video
is that funny but people like it so
whatever do you think that because of
all of your prank videos you're
conditioned to feel less awkward now
yeah I think I've it's helped me build a
degree of I guess thank your skin's
thicker skin yeah probably yeah are
there any prank videos that you did that
just stick out to be like the worst like
skin crawling yeah there's one like
hitting on moms or something almost
picking up older women I was like going
up to the like old ladies in Walmart and
like hey so you want to hang out later
and that was like the hardest one to do
that's why it's just cringy I don't know
like these like they were they were all
nice but it's still like I was like this
young kid I don't know it's just if you
watch the video it's pretty cringy yeah
I mean what you're doing essentially is
causing people to be uncomfortable for
entertainment and it's like it's not a
it's you know it's definitely a cynical
view of it I think that sometimes people
will find it funny yeah made a mark on
their day it's like yeah they got a cup
ranked babe and something unusual happen
they're gonna remember it yeah yeah so
meant to it words it's their day it's
like huh that was really funny yeah
definitely like back in 2012 and 13 it
was so fresh people weren't everyone on
YouTube wasn't doing it then and then
everyone started doing it and so
everyone went
did it later on everyone's always just
one of those videos and my law and then
it was just kind of cringy but you know
what's been amazing is I think we'll
talk about Danny Duncan for a second but
he has like milk I think milk and Danny
Duncan but Danny Duncan that really
never really did pranks no not really
but he's remain like that just done the
same content got better at it over time
yeah he's gone people don't get tired of
it like I watch all of his videos and
they're still just as good as they were
years ago Danny's been he's he's been
really smart you know with hiring
editors and just positioning himself
especially with his merch and I'm really
proud of him I don't and yeah his video
I don't even watch the videos that much
but we're still good friends
yeah those of you guys who don't know
Danny is a youtuber he's got like four
point three four and a half million subs
about and he just does like you know 18
minute 20 minute videos right where you
just kind of just it's crazy but but
it's something about nothing yeah well
him going about his day and it's kind of
like this day's very anxiety yeah it's
kind of like evil old banished yeah yeah
so and they like his personality a lot
ladies yes very but he's very bubble
he's very extroverted um you know you
kind of can just friend mm-hmm
anyone you know mm-hmm so yeah same with
with milk if he's their content they've
stopped doing as many pranks you still
do them every now and then produced
entertaining videos they delivered a kid
a truck for a 16 but just random stuff
but giveaways its entry either zoo mr.
beast man yeah he's been I've seen a lot
of people now doing like the last two
you know leave their hand on the truck
you know yeah it's the truck he thought
was buying their way until you know what
I'm thinking about doing this did you
see mr. beast new app no okay genius
absolutely genius okay so he posted on
Instagram absolute yeah that's when I
was punch anyway so oh you know what
I'll pull it up here so you guys can see
it so you posted this on Instagram hmm
and what it is it's called a finger on
the app so
you gotta do is keep your finger on the
app that's it like that and then every
like 30 seconds or so like a little
bubble will come up and you'll have to
move your thumb over to the bubble and
like red right there and the last one to
leave their thumb to have their thumb on
the app winds up to $25,000 Wow
it's going lie against someone right now
no right now this is practice mode but
on Tuesday at 12 p.m. Pacific Standard
Time
this goes live and probably hundreds of
thousands maybe even millions of people
will be on this app putting their their
thumb on the app like this did not know
that in the last one so but it keeps
going yeah so I so I practice this for a
few minutes and I gotta say like your
your thumb kind of hurts after a while
that's weird to say but like keeping
your thumb pressed down so only see you
can't lift up and switch fingers no wait
I know but it says a penny to a 25,000
why isn't it just say 25,000 yes because
people who lose in determine how much
money the winner gets so there'll be a
sliding scale and you can choose either
a penny or $25,000 and wherever the
average is is how much you can win is
this a plug now did he pay you to say
this now I wish I don't it's gonna be
one of the other and it's probably gonna
be somewhere in the middle but I thought
this would be really fun to do a youtube
video for the Graham Steffen show and
just see how long it can last on it oh I
should do that too yeah we should all
know we're not gonna do this we're all
here for our sleep so so here's another
thing too is that if you play it sounds
like a plug it's not if you play with
two other players and you all have
Bluetooth enabled you can get up to
three extra lines so you could take your
thumb off the app and switch fingers and
switch fingers or something like that
because there's like that little three
line thing extra lines you can do that
but I don't know how long we'd be here
for it's Tuesday at 12 which i think is
a horrible time to do it yeah it's like
it's a middle of the day yeah mr. B's is
trying to think if I have anything going
on Wednesday
morning yep all night ya know the thing
is I don't know how long I bet like the
the thing to move your thumbs around is
gonna be hard or overtime and like
they're gonna try to pull out after a
while man because I'm thinking like if
you know we're like a match so so as
you're doing that right now there's
about 100,000 people also doing that
practice probably okay I'm thinking like
what if this is like a liability issue
because what if someone's like driving
or what if someone's like exhausted
because they stayed up all night and I
know that's common sense but but you can
do that you know you you obviously sign
a disclaimer in the beginning of the app
probably I don't know he probably has
people signing explain yeah but but so I
tried to figure out ways where you could
like move your thumb around or something
like that or like switch off like you
start with two fingers to work yeah I've
tried so many ways to try to game this
starting with two fingers or like
putting your fingers together and then
like spreading them apart and there's
like no nothing so like I would think
that you could like yeah do that but now
hold on anyway I bet there's some way
let's see like you lost how did she yeah
how to cheat the mr. beast out yeah yeah
I've seen so and I saw a video of like a
little machine doing the swipes
automatically for tinder
hmm same yes to everyone mm-hmm just
that's like kind of gaming it cuz he
just yeah then you just pick the hot
girls that you like I didn't know I did
do a mr. B's kind of tribute I read
crime and punishment and that was a
22-hour video Wow
because he remember his old stuff yeah
yeah you know so what I thought about
doing um I didn't do this but reading
the entire stimulus package and it's
eighteen hundred and forty eight pages
but reading it oh my word you know not
live just in one video how do you know
how long it will take you I read a page
and then determine how long that page
took to read and then I multiply that by
eight
is like a few days so yeah no I think I
think the most you can is 24 hours long
video so you have to you would have to
speed it up yeah
yeah I was gonna do the Bible but it's
72 hour read and I wanted I didn't want
to speed it up so I did the crime and
punishment instead yeah it takes
oh you know what my girlfriend too tried
to read out all of her subscribers and
then determined to do that it was gonna
take like eight or nine hours and she
and I think at the time she had like
13,000 or something like that but and
not everyone had two subscribers public
so even then it was like basically an
entire full day worth of just reading
non-stop it's been page by page by page
but it's it's hard though after
two-three hours your throat starts ache
yeah be trying it she did it for two
hours and after that was it like the
camera batteries died like the memory
part filled up but no I'm filing no I
used my phone yeah yeah don't use a real
camera yeah no yeah even with my phone
it was like 80 90 gigs 20-hour video
yeah so Wow I am one thing I really
respect you for is the variance in video
styles or like you know video topics
that you do because you know you did the
pranks you do the chatting with and then
you just have like these randomly thrown
in videos like one of my favorites of
u2's like liddie audio library yeah love
that video I watched that plenty of time
sent that to plenty of friends hmm and
of course you know like your life video
and just utterly you know other radio
yeah I don't know those are just like
random spurts of create inspiration yeah
I don't know a lot yeah yeah you know
you get especially of the audience like
likes it too then you're like a little
cool like I can upload anything I want
there's something like hey so
so for YouTube's liddie audio library it
was just him dancing around to like the
stock music and me yeah you should watch
it I mean I think it's incredible the
choreography everything the choreography
yeah I was just like freestyling you
know you
that was that was some good mood is TJ
oh I knew you were TJ yeah so TJ's are
kind of like the lawyers and the doctors
and the politicians of the world and fps
are like the artists and the the softies
and the people on welfare you know or
unemployment like I am yeah I still had
my little video so I saw it okay yeah
yeah you know it's just like one of
those random like manic moment no no
there wasn't there was hardly any
planning that was just like oh I won't
upload this right now is just the weird
moment I was in a mood you know
everyone's right half of its yeah half
of its like the fun of it's just like
trolling my audience they go what are
the comments gonna be for this you know
yeah like I did a wall I just had a
10-second video of a wall back in like
2014 and the comments on that are
hilarious
so you finally lost it after chatting
with too many stock traders I like that
comment yeah stock traders pay the bills
there was even one more that was like I
want to come on I'll give you four K I
was like I can't do it
yeah nothing like yeah we've turned
Reilly turn they're everywhere I got so
many emails like because they promote
them they're the stock trading platforms
they'll pay you for but they'll make
50,000 on the back end yeah it's not
work and it's and it's usually scamming
yeah I know I like I know I'll make a
quick buck but then it's like I it hurts
the channel so yeah yeah there's just a
balance um are there any videos that
you've done that you thought were gonna
perform really well and they just yeah
well the the rap video we did a rap
video
I remember that one yeah it's good no it
was oh wait wait you're talking about my
roasts myself yeah yeah that one's
actually pretty good I'm proud of that
but that that was like whatever we made
we tried to make a real like rap video
all right
back in 2013 so you were like seven you
know it totally bombed like it got like
20% dislikes which was like unheard of
that can like for me cuz I would always
did pranks and it was like and we spent
like five grand making a like renting
out of this club and all this stuff and
we're like this is gonna go viral I'm
starting a career in this random and
then it just yeah and then it just
bombed so yeah everyone kind of hated
the less good it's gonna do that's yeah
that's very true for a lot of cases but
a lot of work in like an abnormal amount
of work it's a it's probably gonna be a
different style of video and any sort of
different style video typically don't
perform if it's yeah right yeah I think
if grin did a rap video I think it would
do really well no well that's the thing
like the bros myself it depends on the
context like the ROS myself it was all I
spent a lot of time on the lyrics and
like my audience who was like they it
was like all jokes that like the only
they knew about you know so I was like a
little like kind of love letter to my
audience but ostrich I thought the no
yeah the I had a there's one video it's
out like 10 or 20 million now it's just
called actually picking up a girl
yeah it's just it's this 30s no no was
it yes ayan yeah wow she surprised you
knew that I guess she does say it in the
video but yeah I know it's 30 seconds
long and it was on my lap talk for like
six months and then I just uploaded it
one day and it blew up I mean is there
anything that you want to discuss in
particular YouTube Graham um well I just
yeah I got a get start reading that
YouTube Academy free yeah I'll give you
that but yeah I mean we could talk for I
don't I know so if I talk about YouTube
analytics on YouTube yeah people don't
see is people fool people don't care I
don't want to get yeah see my first mic
so wait so where do you see yourself in
five years from now as the quarantine
affected your YouTube channel at all no
it's ad revenue went down but like I
mentioned earlier views doubled because
people took an interest to personal
finance and it's like everyone now is
interested in stock trading like
anywhere you go people are talking about
the stock market what's going on stock
so that's definitely help to the channel
it's brought in an entirely new
demographic especially with stimulus
content because people are interested in
like you know what's happening with the
stimulus and know people are taking an
interest in in politics and everything
like that that they would never be
interested before because now it affects
them so I was able to reach a much
bigger demographic because of that so I
think as a whole it thankfully you know
helped me were you know something like
that was it was in my favor and it just
so happened to be that finance was a you
know what was pushed all your all your
stocks just index funds right like you
don't really play around I do I do I
don't um I started since April buying
individual stocks how do you come into
contact with the people that you have on
your chatting with because you find such
interesting people do they reach out to
you typically or do you find them yeah
I'd say about 80% of them have
volunteered just emailing me or damning
me or some how does that mean did I do
that
mmm I don't remember
okay I set UV yeah it sent you a damn on
Instagram I was shocked because I looked
you up and so you were following me on
Instagram and I was like whoa like
that's so cool I can't believe it so
then I sent you a message and that's how
he set this out I thought from what I
remember I reached out to you yeah but
maybe like I didn't read your DM yet you
know like it was one of those hidden do
yeah yeah we were we were sitting at a
red like a like a cafe Jack and I yeah
and then yeah we were thinking about oh
I think we've watched one of your videos
in John but no we cool of you did that
so I say it's what's your instagrams
like wait what's already well great yeah
that worked out yeah so they typically
reach out to you yeah
80% of the time was there anyone that
you had on and they like opened your
mind up to something maybe that you
hadn't previously considered well yeah
of course most of them you know tell me
something new that I haven't heard use
your perspective on something yeah I
mean like the model she kind of gave me
a new perspective of how like a
stressful it is to you know count
calories or whatever and all that and
how tough management can be about that
and how its kind of a corrupt industry
or in the ex-convict may be like how
jail time is it's like you it's not as
violent as they make it in the movies
but it's you know everyone kind of keeps
to themselves more or something I don't
know just little things I can't really
think about top of my head but yeah you
know what it reminds me what you're
doing a little bit here's a shout out
his Instagram is Rob's 10k friends and
his goal was to go and meet three people
a day every single day until he hit
10,000 people and so far he's meant like
4,000 mm-hmm so I actually saw him I
think I ran across him on Instagram or
something like that or I read something
on Reddit I was read it actually I saw
and read it that that he was doing this
and I reached out to him like hey here
in LA we can meet up and do that and met
up with a really cool guy
but yeah but he just he meets if you're
branded maple does anybody doesn't
matter it's really so here's a shout out
to you rob robs 10k friends okay that's
really interesting yeah I think he's
doing zoom calls and stuff like that now
yeah really just really interesting some
of the insights he's had from this
meeting all of these so you're so you're
on there yeah I would and that was a
couple months ago
no that must have been like a year and a
half ago all right yeah yeah that was
like three years ago for me yeah yeah I
thought that's why you brought it up
no yeah I'm like number like like a a
thousand twelve or something yeah I'm
way back there I know it's back in like
2017 yeah small world but it goes to
show you yeah I mean just how small the
world is and you really get down to it
that's not yeah cuz I had no idea yeah
yeah if you go to his and then go all
the way down I'm somewhere in 2017 I
think I'll find it soon enough but
anyway so yeah so Rob's 10k friends for
anyone watching this you want to be
interviewed volume highly recommend it
was there anyone that you've ever met
that you were surprised that they were a
fan of yours like like some sort of
YouTube Graham yeah really yeah I didn't
know you saw my stuff yeah yeah yeah
that's crazy
um yeah I mean that's what I can think
of for now Oh at the flat earther he was
a fan he was like seeing a bunch of my
vlogs and stuff and so that was
surprising who was someone that you've
met that you fangirled the most over Oh
Jimmy Tatro you know him he's a he's
kind of an actor now he's he's an act
he's like in a in some Netflix show I
forgot but he's like he was a youtuber
and I think I kind of froze up at like
VidCon around him once you know that's
all I can think of for now and maybe
jenna Marbles oh my god he got a little
nervous around her at VidCon yeah when I
first met you I was definitely
fangirling
in same as gran I couldn't oh I don't
know yeah I was nervous 2018 the first
1663 Oh gram is that yeah I think yeah
how did you guys mean I reached out to
him via email and then we went out
simple hello can lead to a million
different things so what you said like
seven emails yes and a lot simple seven
simple hellos yeah yeah I think I'm like
one one one two or something that's cool
small world
yeah I thought I really thought that's
why you brought brought a mug because
he'll sometimes say like this guy met me
through this guy so I figured I figured
you met him through me or something yeah
I won't read it
crazy would you rather fight one
horse-sized duck or a hundred duck-sized
horses one hundred horse sized duck
sized horses doc says horses 100 like
little horses that'd be cute I don't
like that it's scary that's more scary
than a huge duck yeah yeah basically I
mean that's less scary than a huge done
yeah any other what's the other one
the other one that's kind of a silly
ones Danis good what do you what do you
think the first person that ever milked
a cow was trying to do I imagine they um
they saw that there was a lot more milk
in Macau and they're like hey we grew up
on our mom's milk mmm they're like let's
just drink the cow's milk that's that's
smart
yes similar the language there's
language I forget that like is not
allowed thoroughly it's nothing slips
past this one uh
[Music]
it means so much that you'd course no no
I was I'm honored yeah he's both huge
fans of your links and really honored
you'd come course thank you yeah cool so
with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching I really appreciate it
thank you I'm gonna link to all of your
information down below in this
description where you could also get the
YouTube creator Academy for $100 off and
to face down below on that weeble also
make sure and click on all those Amazon
links you like that what else I think
we've said everything that we need to
say thanks for watching YouTube's liddie
audio I mean that was an incredible
flick like I don't know how'd you come
up with come up with it it's just you
have it if you look the music to your
work yeah oh wow yeah what do you add no
on it me I have shoes he's at 225 yeah
I'm at 350 yeah we're gonna keep it in
there for sure I hope that you can see
it getting yeah they like the organ they
like the organic yeah why would they
title it the hell it's terrible
dinosaur dung it's not so